This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二（Guaranteed Human）。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重要时刻。1984对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Keer Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套精神铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你有这个能力，就非得这样做不可。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《Learn the Hard Way》。
And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Welcome back to the podcast for another episode, another week. This week we're talking about big life changes. big life transitions and all of those kind of things that that involves just quickly my little puppy is next to me at the moment because I'm back at home with my family in Melbourne. Kind of why I wanted to do this episode, I guess, is because I'm going through a big life change right now. I'm about to move cities, move jobs, move lives, basically.
欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。欢迎回到本期播客，又是一个星期。本周我们探讨的是人生的重大变化。人生的重大转变以及其中涉及的种种事情。简单说一下，我的小狗此刻就在我身边，因为我回到了墨尔本的家中和家人在一起。我想做这期节目的原因之一，大概是因为我目前正经历着人生的重大转折。我马上要搬到别的城市，换工作，换一种生活，基本上就是这样。
I've just graduated. Yeah, so I really wanted to kind of think about this topic just for my own sake, but also because it's kind of in the intro of the podcast, it's kind of in the name. It's something that, yeah, I wanted to discuss for a while. I think one of the quintessential aspects of our 20s is the big life changes and moves and decisions that we all kind of have to make or the world's going to make them for us. Our 20s is when we decide what we want our life to be, often at time when we move away from home to new cities.
我刚毕业。是的，所以我真的很想思考这个话题，不仅是为了我自己，也是因为这正是本播客导语的一部分，也写在节目名字里。这是我一直想讨论的事情。我认为我们二十岁时最典型的特征之一，就是我们所有人都不得不做出的大大小小的人生改变、搬迁和决定，或者说世界会替我们做出这些决定。我们的二十岁，是我们决定想要过什么样的生活的时候，通常也是我们离开家乡去往新城市的时候。
Like I said, we change jobs, lose friends and make new ones. we might end and start relationships as well. And in our 20s, I think we tend to transition through many. Can you hear the talk? Yeah, we tend to transition through many different lives and lifestyles, choosing ones which kind of fit us best. And the things that are kind of typical in our 20s, like union jobs and travel and starting relationships,
就像我说的，我们换工作、失去朋友并结交新朋友。我们可能还会结束和开始一段感情。而在二十岁时，我觉得我们往往会经历许多不同的生活和生活方式，选择那些最适合我们的。二十岁时那些典型的事情，比如稳定的工作、旅行、开始新的恋爱关系……
ending relationship, gap years, are all massive events in our lives. And what accompanies it is also indicative of big life changes. Like those moves. like new friends and new hobbies and surroundings and that can kind of take a toll i think also as covid has taught us sometimes big life changes and transitions aren't always in our control it's not something that we choose to do willingly and have some optimism about so how do we stay resilient when things can shift so quickly in life especially when we're young and we don't really have the
结束恋情、间隔年（gap year），都是我们生命中的重大事件。与之伴随的也往往是人生的重大改变。比如搬家。比如新朋友、新爱好和新环境，这些可能会带来代价。我也觉得，正如疫情教给我们的那样，有时人生的重大改变和转变并不总在我们的控制之中。这不是我们心甘情愿选择去做并抱持乐观态度的东西。那么，当生活中的一切变化如此之快，尤其是当我们还很年轻，并没有真正拥有……
same security that our older years perhaps might bring if we're lucky I think also it's okay to be scared. It's okay to be kind of terrified that you don't always know where you'll land. And whether what you had before may be better, I think it's worth remembering it always kind of works out in the end, really. But let's discuss the psychology behind these big life changes and shifts in our lives, the emotions that accompany that, and why we have this drive for change and novelty in our younger years.
也许年长一些后如果幸运的话会带来的那种安全感时，我们该如何保持韧性？我也觉得，感到害怕是没有问题的。对于自己并不总是知道最终会落脚何处，以及以前拥有的东西是否会更好，感到某种程度的惊慌失措也是正常的。我认为值得记住的是，到头来事情总会解决的。但让我们来讨论一下这些重大人生改变和生活转折背后的心理学、随之而来的情绪，以及为什么我们在年轻时会有这种对改变和新鲜事物的驱动力。
So this is what we're going to talk about, discovering in our own values and lives, beyond what our parents have kind of decided for us, pushing back, but also wanting to pursue massive changes. I want to talk about loneliness and temporariness, temporariness, people who are temporary, things that are temporary in our 20s, and that constant shedding of old skin, old habits and old versions of yourself and the kind of trial and error that we go through in our 20s to find out who we are, but probably more importantly who we want to be. And that means making mistakes. It means huge changes to our internal conceptions of ourselves and also our external worlds as well. And obviously I'm in my early 20s, so I haven't really experienced the full kind of effect
所以，这就是我们要探讨的内容：在父母为我们决定的生活之外，发现我们自己的价值观和生活，进行抗争，但也渴望追求巨大的改变。我想谈谈孤独感和短暂性、短暂的事物、我们在二十岁时生命中那些短暂的人和事，以及不断蜕掉旧皮、旧习惯和旧自我的过程，还有我们在二十岁时经历的试错，以此来弄清楚我们是谁，但可能更重要的是弄清楚我们想成为谁。这意味着犯错。这意味着对我们内心的自我认知以及外部世界做出巨大的改变。显然我才二十岁出头，所以我并没有真正经历过全方位的……
of those life transitions. This is kind of my first big one as a young adult or by myself. So yeah, kind of looking forward to diving into it and learning some more about how we can kind of coast through these big life changes and what it means for our psychology, how we can do our best to adjust to the cards that life kind of deals us in our young years. So psychologists call the state of being in transition liminality. Liminality.
这些生活转变带来的影响。作为年轻成人或独当一面的人，这是我的第一次重大经历。所以，是的，我非常期待深入探讨它，并进一步了解我们可以如何顺应这些人生重大改变，以及它对我们的心理意味着什么，我们如何能尽最大努力去适应年轻时生活发给我们的牌。因此，心理学家将这种处于转变中的状态称为“边缘状态”（Liminality）。边缘状态。
So it basically means being between social roles and identities. So in other words, it means that you're kind of neither in the state or the life that you've left and nor are you completely in your new life or your new state, at least not mentally. And this can provoke something of an identity crisis that raises the question of who am I, who do I want to be, what am I going to be, what's my life going to be like, which can be quite emotionally destabilizing. And there's heaps of literature on this, obviously, because big life changes are a huge, huge source of stress.
所以它基本上意味着处于社会角色和身份之间。换句话说，这意味着你既不在你已经离开的状态或生活中，也没有完全处于你的新生活或新状态中，至少在心理上不是。这可能会引发某种身份危机，从而引发这样的问题：我是谁？我想成为谁？我将要做什么？我的生活会是什么样？这在情绪上可能会相当具有颠覆性。关于这方面的文献堆积如山，显而易见，因为人生的重大改变是巨大、巨大的压力来源。
And stress is obviously something that psychologists are quite concerned about. I want to look into. So like I mentioned, I'm in a state of liminality at the moment. I'm just about to move cities. I've kind of like packed up my old life in Canberra where I was living. I graduated. I've kind of, you know, I'm preparing to move jobs and move to Sydney. But I'm not quite there yet.
而压力显然是心理学家非常关心的事情。我想深入研究这一点。所以正如我所提到的，我目前就处于一种边缘状态。我正准备搬去别的城市。我差不多已经把在堪培拉生活的旧生活打包好了，我毕业了。我差不多，你知道的，正在准备换工作并搬到悉尼。但我还没完全到那里。
So I'm in this like weird halfway point, staying with my family over Christmas and over the holidays with like one foot in my old life. and one foot like tentatively in my new one as well, which is like quite exciting, but also that luminality stay is very emotionally stabilising. And there's a reason that major life shifts like moving cities or living relationships or jobs can impact our mental health and why it is such a big area of research and interest and it comes down to how the brain functions. So when you change, when you force your life to change,
所以我正处于这种奇怪的中转站，在圣诞节和假期期间和家人住在一起，一只脚踩在旧生活里，另一只脚也试探性地踩在新生活里，这让人觉得挺兴奋，但这种边缘状态在情绪上也非常不稳定。重大生活转折（如搬去新城市、结束恋爱关系或换工作）会影响我们的心理健康，这背后是有原因的，这也是它成为一个备受研究和关注的领域的原因，这一切都归结为大脑的运作方式。所以当你改变时，当你迫使你的生活发生改变时……
when you disrupt your daily or patterned routines, it actually activates the conflict senses in the brain, and this causes brain chaos, and that's what we call cognitive dissonance. And all this kind of research was done by this doctor called Dr. Pallay, who was an assistant professor of psychiatry at Harvard Medical School, the dog, again, in the background. But it's this activation of the conflict sensor,
当你打破日常或固定的生活常规时，它实际上会激活大脑中的冲突感知器，这会导致大脑混乱，这就是我们所说的“认知失调”（cognitive dissonance）。所有这些研究都是由一位名叫帕莱医生（Dr. Pallay）的医生完成的，他是哈佛医学院的精神病学助理教授，背景里那只狗又叫了。但正是这种冲突感知器的激活……
or the conflict area of the brain that creates that stress in people, that creates that dissonance or that chaos that we might often associate with the stress of changing our lives. And with most things in the world of like psychology or just like life in general, not everyone is really affected equally. So this doctor, he suggests that personality, firstly, kind of determines how change impacts our mental health. So for those who rate high in openness to experience, they'll often seek out novelty. And change is usually easier for them to manage because it's something that they can adjust to.
或者说大脑中负责冲突的区域在人们心中制造了压力，制造了那种我们经常将之与改变生活的压力联系在一起的失调或混乱。与心理学或一般生活中的大多数事情一样，并非所有人都受到同等程度的影响。因此这位医生指出，首先，人格在某种程度上决定了改变如何影响我们的心理健康。对于那些在“对经验的开放性”上得分较高的人来说，他们通常会寻找新鲜事物。改变通常对他们来说更容易应付，因为这是他们能够适应的事情。
Perhaps their threshold for stress is a lot higher or their brain and the way that they're made. The temperament just means that they do seek out opportunity more than others. But it's those who feel most comfortable with the status quo or how life has usually been that will find those big changes or transitions to be more challenging just because who they are and the way that their brain is isn't necessarily adapted or equipped to deal as easily with big changes and big disruptions to how they tend to leave their lives. Another thing that really impacts whether you see change is something that's exciting or something that's a bit stressful is the type of parents you have.
也许他们的压力阈值要高得多，或者他们的大脑以及天生的构造。这种气质意味着他们比其他人更倾向于寻找机会。但那些对现状或习以为常的生活感到最舒适的人，会发现那些巨大的改变或转变更具挑战性，仅仅因为他们的个性和大脑的运作方式不一定适应或具备处理这些重大改变的能力，无法轻松应对生活常规的重大破坏。另一件真正影响你将改变视为令人兴奋的事物还是有点压力的事情，是你的父母类型。
So anxious parents, they often pass down that worldview that life is filled with danger and risk. And because of that kind of perception for them, the best course of action is to kind of stick to what is safe and stick to what is unknown. And it's often parents who have experienced trauma or severe poverty or abusive upbringings that implicitly teach their own children that life is this dangerous and unpredictable thing and to just stick to what is known. Don't follow or don't kind of pursue too much change. This might be why we see, you know, friends in our lives
所以焦虑的父母，他们经常会传授这样一种世界观：生活充满危险和风险。由于对他们而言的这种看法，最好的做法就是坚持安全的事物，坚持已知的事物。通常是那些经历过创伤、严重贫困或虐待性童年的父母，在潜移默化地教导自己的孩子，生活是危险且不可预测的，只需坚持已知的事物。不要盲目跟风，也不要追求过多的改变。这也许就是为什么我们会看到，你知道的，我们生活中的朋友……
or people in our lives who are young and who objectively have a lot of exciting opportunities in front of them remain kind of paralyzed by that fear of changing anything because the change might lead to something unsafe. You know, career change could lead to job loss and homelessness or breaking up with a significant other would lead to dying alone. Or, you know, if you've been doing something a certain way, pursuing a particular project or a business or an idea, you know, getting a job for you might actually just be incredibly disruptive. So for people also who have adjustment disorders, which is a real thing, it's in the DSM.
或者我们生活中的年轻人，他们客观上有许多令人兴奋的机会摆在面前，却依然被对改变任何事情的恐惧所麻痹，因为改变可能会导致不安全的结果。你知道的，职业转变可能导致失业和流落街头，或者与重要伴侣分手会导致孤独终老。或者，如果你一直以某种特定方式做事，追求某个特定的项目、业务或想法，你知道的，为你找一份工作实际上可能会带来难以置信的颠覆性。因此，对于那些患有适应障碍的人来说——这是一个真实存在的病症，它被收录在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中。
Change can also be particularly hard, as the name kind of makes it fairly obvious, like adjustment disorder. But basically what this disorder is is it's an emotional or behavioral reaction. to a stressful event or a change in a person's life. And this reaction is considered an unhealthy or excessive response to kind of the thing that is happening. And it often happens within three months of that change happening. So there are six different types, I think, from memory, six different forms of adjustment disorders, which I'm not really going to go into because A, it's kind of boring.
改变也可能特别困难，正如这个名字所暗示的那样，就像适应障碍。但这个障碍基本上是指一个人对压力事件或生活变化的某种情绪或行为反应。这种反应被认为是对正在发生的事情的一种不健康或过度的反应。它通常发生在这种变化发生后的三个月内。所以有六种不同类型，如果我没记错的话，有六种不同形式的适应障碍，我不会真正展开讲，因为第一，这有点无聊。
They're all really similar. And we don't really need any self-diagnosis going on. around these parts, but basically the disorder is an inability to cope. And like I said, there's so much literature on this because major life changes are a massive, massive source of stress, not just the good, not just the bad ones, like a death, but like also the good ones. And if you have an adjustment disorder, it's probably likely that those changes are not going to be as easy or as fun as they might be for other people.
它们都非常相似。而且我们在这个地方真的不需要进行任何自我诊断，但基本上这种障碍就是一种无力应对的表现。就像我说的，关于这方面的文献非常多，因为人生的重大改变是一个巨大、巨大的压力来源，不仅仅是那些不好的、消极的改变（比如死亡），还包括那些积极的改变。如果你患有适应障碍，那么这些改变可能不会像对其他人那样容易或有趣。
So an adjustment disorder, it occurs when an individual stress is kind of, exceed their resources for coping. And this is, there's this woman called Nikki Nance, and she's a professor of psychology at this college in Florida. And she does a lot of work into this. And she says that your reaction with this disorder kind of becomes disproportionate to the event you're reacting to. It's also called situational depression.
因此，适应障碍发生在个人的压力……超过了他们应对资源的限度。有一个叫妮基·南斯（Nikki Nance）的女性，她是佛罗里达一所大学的心理学教授。她在这一领域做了大量研究。她说，你对这种障碍的反应会变得与你所反应的事件不成比例。它也被称为情境性抑郁症。
So the symptoms are similar to that of other depressive disorders, like feelings of sadness, waves of anger and crying spells. However, unlike a depressive disorder or a depressive episode, the symptoms are exclusively triggered by an outside stressor. And they kind of also, luckily for this person or these people, they tend to resolve once the person is kind of adjusted to the situation. But that three-month period, obviously, it's going to kind of suck a lot.
因此，这些症状与其他抑郁症类似，比如悲伤感、愤怒波和哭泣发作。然而，与抑郁症或抑郁发作不同的是，这些症状完全是由外部压力源触发的。而且幸运的是，对这个人或这些人来说，一旦当事人适应了这种状况，这些症状往往就会消失。但那三个月的时期，显然会让人感觉非常糟糕。
And I'm sure there's heaps of people listening who've probably had this type of like disorder even temporarily in their lives or for a moment in time when they've had a big life change and it's just been too much to cope with it's just too much all at once and in general one of the major reasons we struggle with change even for those who don't have this disorder and why it can kind of result in cognitive dissonance is the element of uncertainty and uncertainty it's been said is kind of the enemy of our biological impulses like going back to evolutionary psychology if we're unsure whether an animal is you know a house cat or some like awful beast or tiger we're kind of in trouble if we can't tell the difference if we are uncertain about which it is so our brain doesn't like the odds of equations with unknown variables basically um so it defaults to a negative bias for safety so if you're uncertain about something your brain in your body obviously wants to survive. So if one of the options is, obviously, it's going to be
我确信有大量听众可能在生活中经历过这种类型的障碍，哪怕是暂时的，或者在经历生活重大转变的某一时刻，觉得太难以应对了，一下子承受了太多。总的来说，我们难以应对改变的主要原因之一——即使对那些没有这种障碍的人来说也是如此——以及它为什么会导致认知失调，就是不确定性元素。据说，不确定性是我们生物本能的敌人。回到进化心理学，如果我们不确定一只动物到底是家猫还是某种可怕的野兽或老虎，如果我们分不清它们的区别，我们就有麻烦了。如果我们不确定它是哪一种……
terrible or dangerous. And the other option are it's going to be safe and it's going to be amazing. Obviously, if it's safe and amazing, there's nothing to worry about. But there's also the 50% chance that it's not. And that's the thing that our brain wants us to kind of cope with. So it's going to respond as if it's responding to that negative outcome. And there was a study done and it showed that in people who are uncertain, 75% of people mispredict when bad. things are going to happen. So this uncertainty bias, it kind of trains our brain to expect the worse. And that doesn't mean that change is great and you should expect the best. It's like an amazing thing always, but you should recognize that your brain, it kind of will go into an
因此，我们的大脑不喜欢带有未知变量的概率方程。基本上，为了安全起见，它会默认采用负面偏差。所以如果你对某事感到不确定，你的大脑和身体显然希望生存。因此，如果其中一个选项是，显然它会是……
automatic negativity bias. And think about this next time you kind of get an amazing job offer and you think about the security of your current job or, you know, you've decided you want to move cities, but your brain is going to tell you it's going to speak to you as if this is going to be a negative thing because it's protecting you, which kind of makes sense. And obviously, our thoughts and our impulses aren't entirely out of our control and to kind of help soothe the uncertainty that's causing the brain to fire its stress response, its stress senses as we've kind of talked about. You can kind of use these like neutral self-talk phrases such as like, you know, uncertainty.
可怕的或危险的。而另一个选项是它是安全的，会很棒。显然，如果它是安全且美妙的，就没什么好担心的。但也有50%的几率不是这样。这就是我们的大脑希望我们去应对的事情。所以它会做出反应，就像在对那个负面结果做出反应一样。曾有一项研究表明，在感到不确定的人群中，75%的人会错误预测坏事何时会发生。因此，这种不确定性偏差，在某种程度上训练我们的大脑去预期最坏的情况。这并不意味着改变很棒，你应该期待最好的结果，或者它总是一件神奇的事，但你应该认识到，你的大脑会陷入一种自动的消极偏差中。下次当你收到一份极好的工作offer，并考虑当前工作的安全性时，或者当你决定搬到新城市时，想想这件事。但你的大脑会告诉你，它会以这件事将是一件负面事情的口吻对你说话，因为它在保护你，这其实在某种程度上也是合情合理的。显然，我们的想法和冲动并非完全不受我们的控制，为了安抚导致大脑触发其压力反应（即我们一直在谈论的压力感知器）的不确定性，你可以使用一些中性的自我对话短语，比如，你知道的，不确定性。
It just means that I don't know the future. It doesn't mean that the future is going to be bad. And attempt to rationalize with your brain, intellectualize the kind of stress that you're experiencing. This is one thing that my therapist, who I've kind of ghosted recently, I need to get back on that. But my therapist, she always says to me when I'm worried about change and big moves,
这只意味着我不知道未来。这并不意味着未来会变得糟糕。试着用你的大脑去合理化，把所经历的那种压力进行理性分析。这是我的治疗师总是对我说的一件事，虽然我最近有点不理她了，我需要重新联系她。但我的治疗师，每当我担心改变和重大变故时，她总是对我说
like the one I'm making now, which obviously we've talked about. And what she tells me is to kind of turn fear into something that is exciting. So excitement and anxiety, they activate the same areas of our brains, that being the amygdala and the hippocampus. They use the same kind of neural and synaptic pathways. So by turning your anxiety into excitement, you can ease any accompanying worry. I'll give an example.
就像我现在正在经历的这样，显然我们已经讨论过了。她告诉我的方法是，把恐惧变成一件令人兴奋的事。所以兴奋和焦虑，它们激活了我们大脑的相同区域，也就是杏仁核和海马体。它们使用相同类型的神经和突触通路。因此，通过将你的焦虑转化为兴奋，你可以缓解任何伴随而来的担忧。我举个例子。
So instead of thinking, like, kind of using my example of moving to a new city. So instead of thinking, you know, like, will I make any friends? What if I don't make friends? What if I'm not financially stable? Will I even like my new life? Will I be lonely? It's better to think of it in terms of kind of a positive excitement, anticipatory way of thinking about it.
所以，与其去想——比如用我搬到一个新城市的例子。所以与其去想，你知道的，比如，我会交到朋友吗？如果我交不到朋友怎么办？如果我在经济上不稳定怎么办？我还会喜欢我的新生活吗？我会感到孤独吗？最好从一种积极的兴奋、期待的角度去思考它。
So like thinking that thought of like, oh, am I going to make new friends? Instead of being like, oh, what if I don't? Thinking, you know, who are the new people I'm going to get the opportunity to meet? what exciting things will being alone allow me to do? What opportunities or experiences will I get to have that I can't even fathom yet? Like, imagine all the people I'm going to meet who are going to have a huge impact on my life. And I don't even know their names yet. Like, I have no idea who these people are.
所以，就像去想“哦，我会结新朋友吗？”这个想法。与其去想“哦，万一我没有呢？”不如去想，你知道的，我将有机会遇到哪些新人？孤独会允许我做什么令人兴奋的事情？我会得到什么机会或体验，是我现在甚至还无法想象的？就像，想象一下我要遇到所有人，他们会对我的生活产生巨大的影响。而我甚至还不知道他们的名字。就像，我完全不知道这些人是谁。
And that's like the thing. You can have fear, but that kind of, that thought of who these people are is really exciting instead. And it activates the same areas of your brain. So it kind of tricks your brain into, yes, having. that fear response that it wants to have, but your perception of it is so much different. And I know that positive mind frame philosophy is kind of bullshit for some people, has some doubts surrounding it. You know, like if you just change your thoughts, you can change how you perceive the world.
这就是关键所在。你可以有恐惧，但那种关于这些人是谁的想法，反而真的很令人兴奋。它激活了你大脑的相同区域。所以它有点像在欺骗你的大脑，是的，产生了它想要产生的恐惧反应，但你对它的感知却大不相同。我知道这种积极的心态哲学对某些人来说有点扯淡，周围存在一些质疑。你知道的，就像如果你只是改变你的想法，你就可以改变你对世界的感知。
Like obviously, if a parent has just died, like I don't really see many positives from that. So this is kind of exclusively for things you kind of voluntarily get to do. choose, but it is a pretty powerful tactic for changing fear into excitement, and it works. Here's a quote I saw the other day, and yes, it was on Instagram, but it really did something for me. Here it is. So once we understand that crossing the river of change is the biological, neurological, chemical, and even genetic death of the old self, we have power over change, and we can set our sights on the other side of the river. changing our lives and diving into life changes shifts something really inherent to who we are in the moment
就像显然地，如果一个父母刚刚去世，我觉得从那里面看不出什么积极的因素。所以这基本上只适用于你可以自愿去做、去选择的事情，但它是一个把恐惧转化为兴奋的相当强大的策略，而且它很管用。这里有一句我前几天看到的引言，是的，它确实是在Instagram上看到的，但它确实对我很有启发。就是这样。所以一旦我们明白，跨越改变之河就是旧自我的生物学、神经学、化学甚至基因上的死亡，我们就对改变有了掌控力，我们就可以把目光投向河流的彼岸。改变我们的生活，投身于生活的改变，会改变某些真正内在属于我们的、此时此刻的东西
by changing our surroundings and our environment and everything that we come into contact with. So it's kind of like the death of our old selves and sometimes there is that period between your past life and your new life that can be incredibly uncomfortable, that liminality that we were talking about. And often life transitions involve losses like death, the loss of a job or a relationship ending. And even positive transitions like a graduation or a job offer can make you feel a little bit sad. And, you know, sad because the person we were before in our old selves, our old lives, they aren't bad. And they're incredibly comfortable because we have adjusted to the change that we made beforehand to be that person. but difficult and painful transitions, they can actually yield great understanding of our life's purpose,
通过改变我们的周围环境和我们接触到的一切。所以这有点像我们旧自我的死亡，有时在你的过去生活和新生活之间会有这样一段时期，可能会让人感到无比的不适，也就是我们一直在讨论的那种边缘状态。通常生活转型伴随着失去，比如亲人离世、失业或关系的破产。即使是积极的转型，比如毕业或获得工作机会，也会让你感到有点悲伤。而且，你知道的，悲伤是因为我们以前的那个人、我们的旧自我、我们的旧生活，其实并不糟糕。而且它们让人感到无比舒适，因为我们已经适应了为了成为那个人而事先做出的改变。但是困难而痛苦的转型，实际上可以带来对我们人生目标的深刻理解，
which increases happiness and decreases stress. So it's kind of better in the long run, like eating a really gross vegetable. So there's heaps of research on this and research on how people derive a sense of purpose. And what it's found is that while periods of pain and struggle and change and transitions can make us temporarily unhappy or lonely, or worried. They also make us feel as if our lives have more meaning in the long run. So going through that challenging time of moving cities or right after you've graduated or there's just so many, you know, so many kind of ways that our life changes.
从长远来看，这会增加幸福感并减少压力。所以从长远来看这其实更好，就像吃一种很难吃的蔬菜。关于这一点有大量的研究，关于人们如何获得使命感的研究。研究发现，虽然痛苦、挣扎、改变和转型的时期会让我们暂时感到不快乐、孤独或担忧，但从长远来看，它们也让我们觉得自己的生活更有意义。所以经历那个搬到新城市的艰难时期，或者刚毕业之后的时期，或者仅仅是我们的生活发生改变的那么多、那么多种方式。
But whilst it may be hard in the moment, it actually is a really good exercise for our minds. And an exercise for like our souls as well to kind of put things. to perspective and realize what we really want from life. And the most resilient people will see change as an opportunity rather than kind of a monster to fear because they allow you to consider where your priorities lie, you know, which friends you stay in touch with, what you want from your new life, what you want from your new job, who is this new version of you going to be?
但虽然在当下可能很艰难，它实际上对我们的心智是一个很好的锻炼。也是对我们灵魂的一种锻炼，把事情看清，并意识到我们真正从生活中想要什么。而最具韧性的人会将改变视为一种机会，而不是需要害怕的怪物，因为它们能让你思考你的优先事项在哪里，你知道的，你和哪些朋友保持联系，你对新生活有什么期望，你对新工作有什么期望，这个崭新的你将会是谁？
And what's really important to you? Like where do you see yourself wasting your time and energy and what that kind of brings is a clear sense of your goals and values, and you find that your body and your mind can be much more resilient when it comes to the stresses of change, because all of it is put into kind of a larger scale. And I think above all, prioritising your health in life transitions kind of means not being afraid to ask for help when you need it,
什么对你来说才是真正重要的？比如，你看到自己在哪里浪费了时间和精力，而这带来的是一种清晰的目标感和价值观，你会发现当面对改变带来的压力时，你的身体和心灵可以变得更有弹性，因为这一切都被放在了一个更大的尺度来看待。我认为最重要的是，在生活的转变中优先考虑你的健康，意味着在需要时不要害怕寻求帮助，
especially if you're making a change whereby you're just naturally going to be disconnected from people may have previously had a lot of contact with. It can be really, really lonely. And humans, like I hear this said all the time, I can't believe I'm going to say it on my podcast, but it's so true. Humans are social creatures by nature. So you weren't built to withstand every sudden event in life without the support of others. You're not meant to just like try and force yourself to be lonely because you think it's going to create independence. It's important to kind of reach out. And I think something that we need to remind ourselves and that we kind of know is that it's all worth it in the end. We know that.
特别是如果你正在经历一个改变，在这个改变中你自然而然地会与以前可能有很多接触的人断开联系。这可能会非常非常孤独。人类，我听到这话被说过无数次，真不敢相信我也要在我的播客里说出来了，但这是真的。人类天生就是社会性动物。所以你并不是为了在没有他人支持的情况下承受生活中每一次突发事件而生。你不应该只是强迫自己去孤独，因为你认为这会创造独立性。主动伸出援手很重要。我想我们需要提醒自己、而且我们也知道的一点是，到头来这一切都是值得的。我们知道的。
Otherwise, we wouldn't make the leap. There's something that is pushing you. We would always kind of stay the same until the world forces us to change. It's kind of like what I was talking about, there's people who have that great openness to experience. You know, I have so many friends who have just like completely changed their lives. around so many times and it's not a big deal for them. They travel whenever they want. They change jobs whenever they want. But for others it's not that simple. But I think sometimes staying the same as even more stressful and time consuming and takes more concentration and effort
否则我们不会迈出这一步。有什么东西在推动着你。我们本来会一直保持原样，直到世界迫使我们改变。这有点像我之前说的，有些人对新体验有着巨大的开放性。你知道，我有很多朋友，他们的人生已经彻底改变过很多次了，这对他们来说不算什么大事。他们想什么时候旅行就什么时候旅行。他们想什么时候换工作就什么时候换工作。但对其他人来说，事情并非这么简单。但我认为，有时候保持不变其实会更具压力、更耗时，并且需要更多的专注和努力
because things aren't always in our control, like losing a job or getting dumped or surviving an accident. The world will push us if we don't do it for ourselves. So you may as well just take the leap when you have the chance to be in control. Like, I think COVID was a really good example of this. So many people who I think were like working jobs they didn't like or in cities where they didn't feel connected to their family or trying out this new identities or, you know, pursuing careers or degrees they didn't like. When you go through something like COVID, it kind of forces you to change.
因为事情并不总是在我们的掌控之中，比如失业、被甩或在事故中幸存。如果我们不为自己做出改变，世界就会推着我们前进。所以当你有机会掌控局面时，你不如直接迈出这一步。我觉得新冠疫情就是一个很好的例子。我身边的很多人，我想他们以前做着不喜欢的工作，或者住在对他们来说没有家庭归属感的城市里，或者尝试着新的身份，或者追求着他们并不喜欢的职业或学位。当你经历像新冠这样的大事时，它会迫使你改变。
It forces you to kind of put things into perspective and make a decision. And that's kind of what life does. Like you cannot just stay the same. The world won't let you. But here's the good news. I think even difficult unwanted transitions are usually seen differently in retrospect than in real time. And there's a psychologist called Fila who studies liminality and life changes and transitions quite extensively, actually. He has a lot of really interesting papers if you're into that.
它迫使你把事情看透并做出决定。这就是生活的作用。你不可能一成不变。世界不会允许你这么做。但好消息是，我认为即使是那些困难的、不想要的转变，事后回想起来通常也与当时身处其中的感觉不同。有一个叫菲拉的心理学家，他相当广泛地研究了边缘状态、生活变化和转型。如果你对这方面感兴趣，他有很多非常有趣的论文。
But he found that 90% of the time the people he spoke with about their life changes. changes. They ultimately judge their transition to have been a success insofar that the transition ended and they found themselves once again on solid ground. Even better. Research also tends to show that we see past events, even unwanted ones, as net positives over time, like getting fired from a job. Even though in the moment you might be stressing about financial security and you know, missing your work buddies, it's often judged as a net positive. over time. And though our brains kind of have a tendency to focus on negative emotions in the present, like we were talking about, that automatic kind of process, over the years unpleasant
但他发现，在他所交流过的人群中，90%的人在谈到他们的生活变化时，最终认为他们的转变是成功的，因为转型最终结束了，他们发现自己再次脚踏实地。更好的是，研究还倾向于表明，随着时间的推移，我们将过去的事件（甚至是那些不想要的事件）视为净积极因素，比如被解雇。尽管在当时你可能会为财务安全感到压力，而且你知道，你会怀念你的同事，但随着时间的推移，这通常会被认为是一个净积极因素。尽管我们的大脑在当下倾向于关注负面情绪，就像我们刚才谈到的那种自动过程一样，但多年以后，不愉快
feelings fade more than pleasant feelings do. And it's a phenomenon known as, I think, fading effect bias. Yeah, fading effect bias. And it sounds like a cognitive error, but it isn't. It's not like our brain trying to like trick us. Almost every trend. even the most challenging ones does bear some positive fruit. It just may take some time to see it and feel its effects because in the moment our brain is so worried about that uncertainty element and about what might go wrong and why we need to have that fear. But in hindsight, when you're no longer in that situation
的感觉比愉快的感觉消退得更快。这是一种被称为“消退效应偏误”的现象。是的，消退效应偏误。这听起来像是一个认知错误，但其实不是。这不像是我们的大脑试图欺骗我们。几乎每一个转变，即使是最具挑战性的转变，也确实会带来一些积极的成果。只是可能需要一些时间去看到并感受到它的效果，因为在当下，我们的大脑太担心不确定性因素、担心可能会出错的地方以及为什么我们需要有这种恐惧。但事后回想起来，当你不再处于那种情境中时
where your body is in like flight or fight kind of mode, you're kind of able to appreciate it for what it is. And in his book, Meanings of Life, the psychologist, Roy Bumister, boymister. Can't remember his name. It's called The Meanings of Life. I'm sure that's definitely not a very generic book title. But this psychologist, he argues that a sense of meaning gained through change
当你的身体不再处于战或逃的模式时，你就能以它本来的面目去欣赏它。心理学家罗伊·鲍迈斯特在他的书《人生的意义》中，鲍迈斯特……记不清他的名字了。这本书叫《人生的意义》。我敢说这绝对不是一个非常平庸的书名。但这位心理学家认为，通过改变获得的意义感
makes the rest of life seem more stable. And this is one of the great constellations of like aging and seeing a lot of change is that transitions likely don't cause as much distress. And you might actually be happier because if you've gone through so many periods of ups and downs and roller coasters and transitions, you probably have a pretty stable sense of identity throughout that all and some pretty good priorities about what you want from your life. And the one final thing about big life changes.
让生活的其余部分显得更加稳定。这是变老并经历许多改变带来的巨大好处之一，那就是转型可能不会引起那么多的痛苦。而且你实际上可能会更快乐，因为如果你经历了那么多的起起落落、过山车般的时期和转型，你可能在整个过程中都有一个相当稳定的自我认同，并且对你从生活中想要什么有着相当不错的优先排序。关于重大生活改变的最后一件事是，
I feel like this whole episode has just been me trying to convince myself that moving cities isn't going to be terrible. But another thing is difficult periods can really stimulate innovation and ingenuity. A large amount of literature talks about post-traumatic. growth in which people derive long-term benefits from painful experiences, including more appreciation for life like we've talked about, as well as richer relationships, greater resilience and deeper spirituality. And I think the richer relationships is a big one because when people move or when something changes in your life, if you decide to do something completely
我觉得整集节目听下来，就像是我在试图说服自己搬去一个新城市不会太糟糕。但另一件事是，困难时期真的可以激发创新和独创性。有大量的文献讨论了“创伤后成长”，即人们从痛苦的经历中获得长期的益处，包括对生活有更多的欣赏（正如我们所讨论的），以及更丰富的人际关系、更强的韧性和更深层次的精神信仰。我认为更丰富的人际关系是很重要的一点，因为当人们搬家或者你的生活发生变化时，如果你决定做一些完全
different, you kind of realize who's really there for you in a way and who it's not just convenient to be around but who you actually kind of like and really get along with. And another manifestation of this growth is heightened creativity. This is one of the big reasons why I'm really excited for the next few years of my life, because I think struggle and change really pushes the kind of limits of how your brain sees the world. And I've seen this already. Like breakups are probably the best example of a big kind of shift in your life, kind
不同的事情，你会以某种方式意识到谁才是真正在乎你的人，谁不仅仅是因为在一起方便，而是你真正喜欢并能与之合得来的人。这种成长的另一种表现是创造力的提高。这也是为什么我对未来几年的生活感到非常兴奋的重大原因之一，因为我认为挣扎和改变真的突破了你大脑看待世界的极限。我已经看到这一点了。比如分手大概是生活中巨大转变的最佳例子，那种
of casmic, chaotic. violent shift and change like that brings so many emotions to deal with and process and that can really fuel our creative process because to move past difficult times you really have to embrace them and work through them and work through the sludge and the mud of all the terrible shit that's kind of clogged up in your brain and you have to feel every moment and creating something from that is such a good outlet and I think if you have a mind like that that's often where it's going to go in times of change and transition and stress. That has kind of been, like I said, I feel like this episode is just me
宇宙级的、混乱的、暴力的转变和变化会带来如此多的情绪需要处理和消化，这确实可以激发我们的创造过程，因为要超越困难时期，你真的必须接受它们、经历它们，并穿过你大脑中堵塞的所有可怕废料的泥潭，你必须去感受每一个时刻，并从中创造出一些东西，这真是一个很好的宣泄出口。我想如果你有这样一种思维方式，在面临改变、转型和压力时，它往往就会走向这个方向。就像我说的，我觉得这一集节目就像是
trying to convince myself that this is a good idea. I don't know, maybe I should do like a follow-up episode in a year's time. And I like, if you guys have seen those like Billy Eilish videos where they like record her every year asking her the same questions, it'd be interesting to listen back to this episode in a year's time after I've made the move and see if my predictions about adjustment and cognitive dissonance and new priorities and creativity or right, or whether I'm just like full of crap, or the literature is just like full of crap.
我在试图说服自己这是一个好主意。我不知道，也许我应该在一年的时间里做一期后续节目。我不知道你们有没有看过比利·埃利什的那些视频，他们每年都给她录像，问她同样的问题。如果在我搬家一年后，在我完成了这次搬迁之后，回听这一集会很有趣，看看我对适应、认知失调、新优先级和创造力的预测是否正确，还是说我只是在胡扯，或者文献资料其实都在胡扯。
But yeah, thank you so much for listening. Also, you guys have been really hyping the podcast up recently. Thanks so much for that. I really appreciate it. And like I always say, if you want to support us, or I don't know why I say us, it's just me, but if you want to support me and the podcast more, a really great way to do that is to leave a review on Apple Podcasts. If you have an iPhone,
但是，是的，非常感谢你们的收听。另外，你们最近一直在大力宣传这个播客。非常感谢你们。我真的很感激。就像我常说的那样，如果你想支持我们——我不知道为什么我要说“我们”，其实只有我一个人——但如果你想更多地支持我和这个播客，一个非常好的方法就是在Apple Podcasts上留下评论。如果你有iPhone的话，
kind of allows more people to find this content and to hear my voice. It's kind of weird to say that. But if you do feel cool to leave a review, I really appreciate it. It really does help us grow. Once again, it helps me grow. And brings kind of more listeners to this space. in the world, space in the metaverse. If you're going through a big life transition as well, as I'm sure many of you are,
这基本上可以让更多的人找到这个内容并听到我的声音。说出这话感觉有点奇怪。但如果你确实觉得留个评论很酷，我会非常感激。这确实有助于我们成长。再次重申，这有助于我的成长，并为这个世界的这个空间、元宇宙的这个空间带来更多听众。如果你也正在经历生活中的重大转型，正如我相信你们中的许多人一样，
I know it's the end of the year, so graduations just happen, everyone's moving. I can feel it all around. Then hopefully this kind of brought some insights into what you might be experiencing and why it's maybe normal or what to expect and why at the end of the day it's really just kind of worth it. So thanks for tuning in and listening wherever you are listening. I hope you're having an amazing afternoon, morning, evening, just an amazing day. And thanks for listening to the very end.
我知道现在是年底，所以毕业季刚刚过去，每个人都在搬家。我能感觉得到周围到处都是这样。希望这能带给你一些启发，让你了解你可能正在经历什么，为什么这可能是正常的，或者该期待什么，以及为什么到头来这一切都是值得的。感谢大家收听，无论你在哪里收听。希望你度过一个美妙的下午、早晨、夜晚，度过美妙的一天。感谢你收听到最后。
You're my very special listener. And you'll be hearing from me very soon. That's a bit weird. But anyhow, thanks guys. And have a lovely, lovely day. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
你是我非常特别的听众。你很快就会听到我的声音。这听不管怎样，谢谢大家。祝你们度过美好美好的一天。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、体能和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的姿态走出困境。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，只需搜索TWO%。在《Look Back》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集中，我们选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是由真人制作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。